hey marvel fans we're here with david
dussmalchen we are on the carpet right
now for marvel spider-man no way home
right now how excited for you or for
this carpet i'm so excited i'm being
back on a marvel red carpet at a
premiere for a marvel film and it's
spider-man and all the exciting things
that are about to happen in this movie
that i've just been teased by with the
trailer i'm like
i know we're all about to get our minds
blown but uh this is like historic
marvel filmmaking right now because
there's all these elements to this new
movie that we've never gotten to see
before absolutely is there anyone you're
super excited to see on the carpet today
uh i was really hoping i get to run into
alfred molina uh i don't know if he's
around um i mean tom and zadea and all
the incredible stars of this movie like
i'm big fans of everybody that is a part
of the movie so
i'm just
geeking out over everybody that's
awesome now spider-man is beloved by the
entire world what makes them so
relatable to you and everybody else
it's like when you're a teenager and all
of a sudden your everything starts
changing and the world seems like it
doesn't make any sense peter parker is
the embodiment of that for all of us
he's like his body starts changing all
these things start happening that he has
no control over and all of a sudden he
has this choice to make like what am i
going to do with all this change am i
going to do something
to make the world better or am i going
to
turn all that anger and confusion and
fear into something dark and he
continues to inspire us because over the
decades peter parker and spider-man
continue to rise the occasion and be the
hero that we need them to be i
absolutely love that hope positivity
enjoy the red carpet thank you so much
for being here thank you thank you
thanks everybody
[Music]
you